you will start to get to a point in your  career where your growth starts to slow  down but that's also when your  contribution to the firm starts to  increase  and you become more valuable to the firm  but at this point in terms of growth  you're actually giving more than you're  gaining I feel like there's this  mentality in architecture that you have  to work under someone that you have to  intern under someone for like years and  years and years to become a good  architect but I have come to believe  that once you have the fundamental  skills it's a matter of gathering  knowledge and there's a much faster way  for you to gather knowledge than  spending eight hours a day at the office  magically trying to absorb that  information and you can do that either  through focused learning you know taking  classes or reading or reaching out to  your network and this isn't just for  architecture this is with other  disciplines as well